but like i've seen them trolling you and
i'm just like have you ever been to a
point where off camera you're like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill one of these kids
i'm gonna kill one of them not because
like it's always in playful manner but
there has been more it's the [ __ ] uh
electrocution [ __ ] the taser the taser
there was a little part of you
no but this is the crate it's like do i
say it's like
it's not real really yeah
that was set up call me leonardo
dicaprio baby let's do it i'm in this
[ __ ] give me an oscar someone give me
an oscar no it's not it's yeah it's like
we you know now set up in terms is set
up like is it set up like like you think
i'd really let someone tase me and not
beat the [ __ ] out of them okay question
serious think about it is it set up like
hey we're gonna do something play along
with it but i'm not gonna let you know
what it is or is it set up like hey i'm
gonna [ __ ] tase you no it's it's like
it's kind of like you know some shit's
gonna go on
like
play along with it play okay okay
but you don't know exactly what it's
gonna be yeah no not all the time no
got you yeah okay that makes a little
bit more sense interesting like they're
a b-shape where i'm like oh of course
but i see it right away i'm like oh okay
this is what it is okay [ __ ] like
because i remember seeing that there's
some [ __ ] that i'll be like after the
fact i've kind of been like yo don't
don't do [ __ ] ever do that again like
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you matter of
fact don't put that on the internet yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because
that's the other thing is like you have
the ability
it seems like you could beat any of them
up
every single one of them probably at the
same time together well that's the fight
yeah but i launched the fight
[Music]
boys
i love them i love them they i like i
only uh uh know uh saleem and he's a
good kid he's sweet he is that
[ __ ] makes me laugh bro so yeah
salim is a [ __ ] he's a good moaning
[ __ ] yeah
that i have cried at that yeah he's
funny man he's a he's a good dude he's a
really good dude yeah okay steve's a
[ __ ] amazing dude that's like my
brother man i'm not as familiar with
with steve i know a little of kyle's
stuff from the pod right and um i was
surprised you weren't involved in that
yeah well i kind of was here and there
like i did a few episodes with them yeah
but i don't know i figured for some
reason that you guys would do that
together yeah i don't know there's
there's a i don't know there's a little
thing i don't know what did you would
did you also feel that way a little yeah
that's interesting but it's all good you
know i'm like all right it's fine yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know maybe i
don't know
what i don't know
yeah
but i'm like dude i guess because i know
i i don't know it's just i don't know
what what dawg you could talk about it
i think i don't know yeah yeah yeah no
it's just like
i would have loved to have been a part
of it i just figured that synergy would
be perfect yeah yeah and i think we did
episodes and it was and again i don't
know their business so i can't say but
like i i can understand people want to
create their own things 100
and i'm sure that's something that you
like doing i'm sure it's something that
everybody assuming wants to create their
own things for sure and uh that is also
the demise of every great band but it is
okay
and we hope that mine is for every game
you know john lennon want to go create
his own [ __ ] [ __ ] all that [ __ ] john but
uh no no but i i can see that urge to
kind of like have that soul
focus and soul like vision when it comes
to to creating a problem for sure yeah
and i'm not mad at all it's like again
they they they make great [ __ ]
decisions you know yeah so it is what it
is no they're bowling i would have loved
your guys your stuff i don't know again
i'm an outsider i'm not as involved in
the content like i'm [ __ ] 38 you know
what i mean but from the outside like
you guys have really this really fun
chemistry yeah so i was like i don't
know kind of seems like this
i felt the same way like i i don't know
for me i'm like a creator so i'm going
yeah you have these nfl guys on but like
have bradley just body slam every single
one of them and like let's see who's the
real athlete right like
imagine that
there's just fun stuff like yeah you and
ab have a vert competition yeah that'd
be fun
yeah i think you got a b
i i mean i don't know
on a standing vert i think standing
versus yeah standing bird that's another
m we'll go back home but like standing
vert is different like i'm a one leg
jumper so you're a runner i could dunk
yeah yeah back in the day now no yeah
how tall are you from
yeah like still for like six two like
dunking is probably like a little bit
surprising during a basketball game but
when i saw the vert if you're a
basketball guy like you know vert's
different like dominique wilkins was a
crazy dunker because it was off of two
feet yeah i do everything i've heard
you can't do no that's the thing i don't
i don't have that [ __ ] single leg
finesse i've also never tried it
well maybe you should [ __ ] try it i
should try off the vertical because
sometimes
maybe it's really like that i just never
really tried it okay because it's more
of the ball the the paws the ball
handling the kill yeah yeah i didn't
have that finesse to like you know what
i'm saying so yeah you weren't dribbling
up to go dunk exactly as long as you
could hold it you could do it you were
doing like gym box jump training to the
point where yeah i mean it was most of
my jump training came from the olympic
lifting when i was younger and so i was
like because that's all like
pretty much explosive verb yeah yeah but
obviously you got the barbell so that's
where it came from so it was never like
because i'm you're one you're in one
spot you're not like running to go do
that yeah yeah um what's your pr for
vert i don't even know dude i never
really tested it but actually i think
remember that guy came by the gym
there's a guy who has a world record
came by the gym and he said the world
record was like what 67 or some [ __ ]
and mine was like mine i remember mine
at the time was must have been 63. this
is before the record was standing first
then invert
this remember no he measured this right
there's no way
you could maybe hit a box that was 63.
no no it was up to my shoulders like
that's where it was feet
standing vert yes it's like i'm three so
it's like up to here
like maybe a little bit like a little
bit there but this kid this kid blew way
past it he's shorter than i am and he
did the standing vert even higher but
this was he's supposed to he's the best
he's about you're a guy on youtube
you're not supposed to waste 260 pounds
that's the thing that i was talking
about i wasn't literally doing this
video with this kid and i was like crazy
i wonder if the best linebacker that
never played in the united states that's
pretty funny
crazy bro it's weird i don't know dude
should we get you a tryout that's a
video i don't know bro that is a video
are you kidding me how many years people
have been fun you know how many years
since i've been doing social media yeah
i've been i've been like do the nfl
thing try out do this you know what it
is there's so much technique so the
problem is that's the thing yeah i'm not
exactly i mean i'm not those guys like
it's like you could probably take an nfl
guy and have him work out with you and
you could you could look at him and go
man if i trained him in technique
probably lifts so much for like he's
limited by texas but there's there's
difference it's like skill yeah on this
field and then there's like like
application of like a physical feat it's
different yeah yeah yeah no matter how
much you think that's what you're saying
if i did it when i was younger and i
would learn all the skills cause like
there's no way i can't relate to like
these these nfl players like they spent
like the skill work is still so goddamn
it's like everything yeah doesn't matter
how actually like
you know if you don't have the actual
skill or like the you know knowing okay
where what's happening yeah it doesn't
matter how [ __ ] actually like
athletic like you are yeah right to a
degree
i think we need to set up that match mma
rules you versus all three of them elk
boys
yeah i'll do it they wouldn't
no of course if i'm them i wouldn't no
they would and i wouldn't even want to i
wouldn't even want to like to be honest
i wouldn't want to fight stephen what if
you just have to tap them out
that with three people [ __ ] and they
could hit you wild yeah i know like
while you're trying to tap them out
knowing them i'd be like just watch
you grab up saleem if i'm them i'm like
i think we just got to watch this happen
i think i could tap saleem out while
still getting punched
yeah like in the face
though steve is strong steven strong
steven strong you have to go for him
first
dude why would anyone not that's what
i'm saying like i'm 38 if i was gonna
lift to like get diesel you're out of
your mind if you think i'm not using
steroids if you see me again in my life
get shredded you know exactly what the
[ __ ] it is i'm saying it right now on
the pod you all know exactly what the
[ __ ] it is